wow is this real Sports Illustrated when
2023 oh my gosh I am gay but it's doing
stuff for me that's a massive hat that's
enough hat for the two of us that is an
umbrella this is what when I'm older
this is what I want to give big hat on
the beat Shannon my Pom-Pom I do have to
ask uh free feet pick I don't like feet
but I like her feet okay she's at the
watering hole horses who's this man in
the back with the horses I think that
this kind of shows that like Martha's
one of us she too gets photobombed by
three giant horses in the background and
one stallion riding one she's 81. 81
that's a lie actually I thought she was
like in her 60s 80 is the new 60. 60 is
the new 40 and 40 is the new 20. I mean
she looks hot I'm proud of her I love
her Martha call me I love seeing a woman
a woman confident in herself sexy
laughing
Martha hehehe